[Musique]
bonjour bonsoir merci d'être avec nous
sur rt france se soit alors on l'a dit
un c'est le plus vaste plan de sauvetage
économique de l'histoire des etats-unis
est-il selon vous à l'autre à la hauteur
de l'enjeu
question quel est l'enjeu
l'enjeu c'est de maintenir l'économie
américaine et cela reste à voir
car il s'agit de deux milliards de
dollars
ce sont 500 milliards pour les
entreprises ne savons pas exactement
lesquelles celles qui en auront besoin
puis 350 milliards pour les travailleurs
mais ne savons pas quelle forme cela
prendra
nous savons pour le moment que les
travailleurs auront des allocations au
chômage de l'assurance et qui le seront
également
600 dollars supplémentaires par personne
par rapport à la somme normal si en cas
de licenciements liés aux coronavirus
alors on pourra même peut-être recevoir
quatre mois de salaire en plus des
allocations donc cela pourrait aider les
travailleurs mai 2000 milliards de
dollars c'est presque trois fois plus
que le plus vaste de plan de sauvetage
économique sous l'administration obama
en 2008 qui était à hauteur de 830
milliards de dollars cela ne pourrait
aider les travailleurs que pendant
quelques semaines
donc si un dépasse quatre semaines alors
cet argent disparaîtra le plan de
sauvetage
est discutée depuis vendredi dernier aux
états unis au sénat américain nous
sommes mercredi
pourquoi les débats ont été si long ce
qui a pris beaucoup de temps c'est que
au sénat le plan a été adopté
aujourd'hui mais beaucoup de discussions
sur ce qui devrait en faire partie ou
non les législateurs discuter de cela
senna on a mis en place une disposition
interdisant au président qui possède
beaucoup d'hôtels qui sont touchés par
la crise dans le monde représente ne
pourra pas recevoir d'argent et le
vice-président non plus où les membres
du congrès où les membres de l'exécutif
et de l'administration ne pourront pas
toucher des aides
donc cela retarder le processus c'est
une autre question c'était combien
quelle somme d'argent serait fléchés
pour les hôpitaux mais il y a encore des
problèmes au niveau de l'argent qui sera
ajouté pour d'autres projets dans ce
plan de sauvetage des lobbys et des
membres du congrès continue à débattre
là dessus donc il s'agissait de se
débarrasser de ces questions avant toute
chose alors souvent le président
américain une grave récession pourrait
faire plus de victimes que coronavirus
est ce qu'aujourd'hui donald trump
mesure vraiment les effets de l'épidémie
je pense qu'il mesure mais aux états
unis
il y a un sentiment général qui est le
rejoint le courant n'a virus a causé
environ 790 morts à ce jour c'est
beaucoup de gens mais c'est très loin du
nombre de morts qu'on a condamné cette
année lié à la grippe saisonnière la
grippe saisonnière qui a tué vingt mille
personnes ne serait-ce que cette année
le concours navires us il n'est pas
contrôlée pourrait peut-être être pire
mais beaucoup de personnes je commence à
dire et
s'agit pas que du président que si
l'économie s'enlise
ce vendredi beaucoup de personnes
pourraient pointer au chômage et on
s'attend à avoir environ 4 millions de
personnes et le record date et déjà il
ya plusieurs décennies sous
l'administration reagan
donc on s'attend à recevoir 4 millions
de demandes pour le chômage et donc
l'interruption de l'économie on s'y
attend pour avoir des effets
dévastateurs à long terme
pourrez vous plonger beaucoup de
personnes dans la pauvreté en france le
ministre de l'économie a dit que
l'impact du coronavirus aux états unis
est décisif pour l'économie française
elle est l'impact du corona virus aux
états unis aura aussi un impact
économique dans le monde vous pensez les
faits aucun d'orsay
la réaction des états unis et les
conséquences niveau des marchés aura des
conséquences dans tout le monde dans le
monde entier
nous sommes également conscients du fait
que lorsque le corps de sauvetage a été
accepté il ya eu deux jours où les
marchés sont remontés aux etats unis
c'est très positif
mais la question c'est combien de temps
cela va durer car les marchés et wall
street sont très différents des
sacha de la vie de tous les jours et
s'agissant des emplois du secteur des
services des coiffeurs des mécaniciens
ce sont ces personnes qui ne sont pas
représentés par wall street
donc wall street remonte un peu mais ces
personnes qui doivent rester chez elles
ne travaillent pas ne sont prêts à payer
verront leur vie changer profondément
donc c'est la question est ce que ces
personnes peuvent tenir le coup merci
beaucoup benson d'avoir été avec nous ce
soir sur arte france
je rappelle que vous êtes journaliste
d'investigation merci beaucoup vous
étiez en direct d'attentât aux états
unis